luxury high-rise condo project could
soon be coming to the hills of henderson
this is a first high-rise living project
for the city it would go near tranquil
peak court and serenity point drive in
mcdonald's highlands joe moeller is live
near there with when this could get
started and some of the local reaction
hi joe
hey there brian the proposed project is
expected to be heard by the henderson
city council coming up on december 7th
now the developer wants to take the
amenities you can get out there on the
las vegas strip and bring them to the
hills in henderson with this spectacular
view
it's going to be unique to the valley
these are called the pinnacle residences
it's going to raise the bar of
sophistication for luxury real estate
the two luxury condo towers would be
built in between these ridges on the
eastern side of mcdonald highlands
listing agent kristen ruth silverman
says this project will be unique to the
area the pinnacle residences are
designed to be houses in the sky there
will be 171 condos with a price tag
between 2 and 12 million dollars by
going vertical they take up less land
this project will take about 11 acres
instead of 75 acres developer rich
mcdonald says this is being built for a
specific clientele and the nice thing is
it's a three-quarter of a billion dollar
project mcdonald says this project will
bring money to the valley and create
jobs we're going to create jobs for
about 550 billion dollars that'll be
local henderson jobs the city of
henderson planning commission went over
the project details earlier this month
and it goes in front of city council in
december i think for the city it would
be great tax wise i spoke to some
residents who live nearby while some say
it could increase home values others are
concerned about the increase in traffic
and changing mountain views i'm not
crazy about the high-rise towers i was
really excited about the high net worth
homes they were going to be building up
there
again the henderson city council is
expected to take this proposed plan up
on the december 7th city council meeting
if they do get the green light the
developer expects to move dirt at the
location in the spring reporting live in
henderson this evening joe muller live
local now